Sir Charles Barkley had a legendary
career in the NBA for 16 seasons he has
since become a popular and outspoken
analyst on TNT's inside the NBA Barclays
has a new TNT documentary series
discussing race relations it is called
American race in one episode he speaks
with alt-right founder Richard Spencer
and civil rights attorney Gerald Griggs
you know we don't want anything
different in life than you do
are you sure not that you just want what
white people want yes yes I want a good
family yeah I want a good job I want my
daughter to live in a world which she's
late doesn't have to worry about
discrimination but that's all we want
Charles Barkley Jones is now good
morning
good morning thanks for having me I
exist early for you to get up in the
morning yes I'm not a morning person
that'd be good we're glad you're here
thank you
ah that's nothing you can do early naman
you can't do later in the day so tell us
how you feel about this that's not true
you are so much said nothing happens
good after 10 o'clock at night just fine
let's talk about this series yes boredom
series yes uh and you're engaged by this
you seen it was the hardest thing I've
ever done in my life meeting with these
families obviously Richard Spencer and I
meeting with mothers who families who
kids have been killed by the police
meeting with Muslim people and
undocumented immigrants they were very
difficult conversations but they need to
be had this is where I saw the episode
in Baltimore where you go and they were
talking about the riots and you said you
don't understand why people riot and
tear up their own stuff race is so
tricky and so difficult to talk about
because nobody wants to talk about race
Charles I'm so glad you're doing it well
and that's the biggest problem we never
talk about reason to something bad
happen and then everybody's mad yeah
right so what I want to do is like I
want people to watch and sit around says
does he have a point this she have a
point that they have a point
but nobody everybody is so afraid and
you shouldn't be afraid to talk about it
they got mad at you in Baltimore when it
seemed like you were defending the
police
well Coolatta he
it and I had no problem with that first
of all I've always defended the police
but that doesn't mean I think they're
always right first of all we need to
police especially in the black community
but that doesn't mean they don't make
mistaken to heaven did things wrong we
have to find a way to hold police
accountable when they do things wrong
but I it was it was important for me
first what was a painful night number
one I could see them but it felt after
it was over I bet you that lady had
never had an opportunity to express what
she felt to the news media because the
news media wouldn't go spend time with
her and she was angry at me and she was
angry because her son got killed before
in our community makes mistakes too well
party and I've gotten in trouble because
I think we as black people we got to do
better ourselves you know black on black
crime it's a travesty yes and we can't
keep treating each other with such
disrespect being called the cops when
things go bad get mad at the cops we
have to start policing ourselves much
better what did you learn I learned some
amazing people out there and I met a
pastor in Atlanta who works with
undocumented immigrants kids he has an
after-school program because those
people are amazing working hard all the
time but he started a a after-school
program where these kids go I met with a
Muslim family what did you learn about
and those people are interesting and
powerful what'd you learn about how we
can take the right step forward in terms
of race well what number one you the
only thing you can do is talk about it
but I wanted to put a face like the
mother in Baltimore lots of Sun we see
it like in a little blurb on the news
for five to seven seconds then we go to
the next story I wanted to give like
that's a real person
yeah the undocumented immigrant they're
like real people
same thing with Sharmini the Muslim in
Irving Texas we throw those words around
we talk about brutal police brutality
but we don't ever see that victims face
we talk about undocumented immigrants
but we don't really know any of them
you're showing a human side yes there's
a big story in the news with Adam Jones
yes who was called the n-word was on the
field did that ever happen to you did
you ever experience anything like that
sure racial slurs while you're on the
you the monkey thing slur the monkey
thing but you know you go back and look
at Adam Jones situation number one
obviously was wrong but I was more
disappointed in the people around the
people saying the recent stuff because
if just out of human decency the people
around shoulda policed that situation if
I'm sitting at an event what is white or
black and somebody is insulting somebody
who's Hispanic Jewish black or whatever
I'm going to stand up and say something
so to come back the next night and give
him a standing ovation that was that was
ridiculous but the people who were
sitting there that night letting some
people scream slur that out them they
should have polish that situation better
Thank You Charles great to have you
thank you for having me good to see you
like really good to see you